[Music]
so downton abbey new era is obviously
set in a very specific time in british
history and i know
you worked with a lot of vintage
textiles for this project can you
explain that process a little bit was
that any more difficult than working you
know with sort of modern fabrics
um yes it's infinitely harder and harder
to find um especially during covid our
way of working and during that time was
really challenging and then harder to
maintain and they require a lot of
restoration and sort of bringing them up
to scratch so that they are camera ready
and then you're working with these
really delicate pieces to either um
incorporate them into a new make or just
restore them as they are so i mean we're
surrounded by vintage textiles just
within this small selection here yeah
and they're beautiful absolutely
beautiful but i was curious
in terms of a film that's set in a time
like this
how do you combine historical accuracy
with
creating an aesthetic because obviously
you want a cohesive look for these
pieces how much are you willing to sort
of sacrifice like absolute historical
accuracy for for a good look that's a
very good question and i think downton
is famed and really prides itself on its
authenticity and its historical accuracy
but i think those two things are
slightly different
um and whilst we're striving for full
authenticity it's not always entirely
historically accurate it can't be and my
way of of thinking about it is that i'm
curating it with a modern viewpoint so i
am looking at the construction and the
way the costumes are put together and
using textiles that would only have
existed at that time
but some of the textiles are modern so
it's not you know it can't be 100 but
it's about always striving for it to
feel as authentic as i can
and and i think by using vintage
materials accessories jewelry beading
um even a button that anchors it to that
time and makes it feel more authentic
um and you're sort of viewing it through
a contemporary lens so it's like it's
our take on what as an audience we would
find the most covetable from that time
and putting that together
did you have any sort of sort of style
icons that you look to for reference
maybe hollywood stars for you know
mernadel galatian things like that
yes absolutely we looked at all the
hollywood greats and we were looking at
marlene dietrich
greta garbo myrna loy um
yeah like you know all of the sort of
superstars of that era and looking at
what was different about hollywood
glamour the sort of high octane beauty
sitting alongside the kind of classical
beauty of the ladies of downton so it
was a lovely sort of juxtaposition of
two very different aesthetics yeah i was
going to ask you know you've got the the
costumes for the trip to the south of
france you've got the hollywood costumes
you've got the regular downton costumes
that must have been a challenge right to
come up with so many sort of different
looks for you know very different sets
of people right definitely but it was
lovely i mean i think when i first got
the script every page i turned it was
like oh hooray like this this whole you
know a new challenge a new chapter a new
look and being able to explore
completely different palettes was really
refreshing and being able to contrast it
with the palette that we you know know
and love so much from the abbey itself
so um it was a glorious challenge um but
it was it was a very prolific film in
terms of costumes so there were a great
number of them but they were all like
equally wonderful to to find and define
that way yeah did you in designing in
terms of emotional journeys with
characters did that play into the design
at all or was it more sort of the era
and the the aesthetic that you were
looking for i think it's always a
balance of those two things and i think
you know downton is very well
established and we know the characters
but that doesn't mean that they're
static they're always moving through
time and there's always things happening
to them and they're inhabiting a world
so we're always looking to tease out
what those story arcs are um but some
people more than others so for example
lucy is completely different in this
film to how we saw her in the last film
and her circumstances have completely
changed so it gave us the opportunity to
really express her through clothing and
have fun and sort of show a kind of
blossoming of her style because she all
of a sudden had the ability to to you
know publicly wear whatever she wanted
to wear so well that was all my
questions so thank you so much thank you
very much indeed